One of the things that people are very
much confused by in the modern world is
what our tech people meant by Gods.
And that's because whatever the day
these were that had the motive force,
that archaic people attributed to the
Gods seem to have disappeared in modern
culture.
Now the young end hypothesis is that's
because they turned into psychological
traits fundamentally or motivational
forces.
So what the,
what archaic societies would describe as
Gods,
we would describe as motivational
forces.
So for example,
Venus is a goddess,
the goddess of love,
and we would associate her power with
love and sex fundamentally.
And the reason that that's an reasonable
association from the archaic standpoint
is because the mode of quality that
makes up what Venus represents is
transpersonal,
which means it's not limited to one
person and it's immortal in that the
motive force that characterizes sexual
affiliation exists,
whether or not a single individual
exists.
So it's transpersonal has the force of a
personality because if you fall in love,
you're motivated by a certain set of
standards and perspectives,
right?
If you're gripped by beauty,
say or if you're gripped by lust that
imposes a particular view of the world
on you and impels your action sometimes
despite your will.
And so that would be equivalent from the
archaic perspective to possession.
And it's clearly the case that archaic
societies who were engaged in warfare
for example,
would conduct rituals to ensure that the
warriors that made up their societies
were in fact possessed by the correct
God.
So might be Mars,
for example,
the Roman God of war,
so that on the battlefield they
exhibited the proper characteristics of
somebody who was in a battle,
right.
Rage.
You can think rage,
sole possession by the god of war would
be equivalent to this possession by a
state of rage.
No,
it's not quite that simple.
It isn't the only that archaic people
externalized motive forces and gave them
the status of Daddy's.
What they did was more complex than not.
And I think you can understand that a
little bit better if you start to,
if you start to give some thought to the
modern behavioral notion of the stimulus
and the stimulus is a very,
very weird concept because the behavior
is who weren't interested in taking
apart what was inside the brain would
attribute motive force to the stimulus,
right?
They'd say if you present an animal with
the stimulus,
he will therefore act.
And that meant that the behaviors were
making the presupposition that the
motive power resided in some manner in
the stimulus.
Well,
why,
why would they think like that?
Well,
it's an archaic mode of thought in a
sense.
You could imagine a child saying,
um,
one of my friends today made me really
angry.
Right?
Which means that the child is
essentially conflating his or her own
internal emotional state with the
proximal stimulus that gave rise to that
state.
And you see complex associations like
that taking place with regards to the
apprehension of beauty.
Say,
because beauty is a very,
very complex and difficult to localize
phenomena.
If you're very attracted to someone,
are you attracted by them?
Well,
in a sense,
of course you are because they are the
are.
But in another sense you're not at all.
Because what's happening is that you're
engaged as much in the attraction as
anything that's motivating you from the
outside world.
And I think that partly accounts for
your sense of foolishness,
especially if the person that you're
attracted to doesn't return your
attraction.
I mean,
you know that from your perceptual
perspective,
you're attracted and dominated by the
object.
But by the same token,
you know entirely that easy as it is to
presume it's them and their faults say
pretty much it all has to do with you.
So in the modern world where we've been
able to separate out the object and the
motive force of the object,
the daddies have sort of moved inside of
us and becomes psychological forces.
But you can understand if you think
about it in this manner that things
weren't so clear prior to the dawn of
the empirical age.
That gives you a little bit of
background with regards to what the
notion of Daddy meant to archaic
societies who still utilize those
notions as explore explanatory terms.
Okay.
So we know that if you're caught up in
one of these little,
uh,
world games that you may be motivated by
something very,
very fundamental,
right?
A tendency that transcends you,
the tendency to propagate yourself,
say Freud's fundamental motivational
level sexual affiliation or the tendency
to maintain yourself.
Those you could say are the fundamental
gods of existence,
the fundamental driving force has,
and it's there.
It's the interaction of those two forces
over great periods of time that produced
the great diversity of life and human
life that we see before us.
And each of those fundamental,
most fundamental of gods have their
differentiated many.
And so to speak.
So that well engaged in the met had a
goal of self preservation.
You Act out plots of hunger and plots of
thirst,
and he moved from cold to hot or from
heart to call depending on your
particular,
uh,
on your particular,
on the particular temperature of your
surroundings or with regards to self
propagation.
You're attracted to people who are
repelled by them for reasons that are
frequently absolutely beyond your
comprehension,
by the way.
So I just found out this week,
and this is absolutely staggering.
I think that if you,
uh,
if you run an experiment on a group of
women and you track their menstrual
cycle and then you give them t shirts
that men have worn to smell,
that women who are operating like the
smell of symmetrical men better than
asymmetrical men.
So,
and that's partly because symmetrical
men are probably more healthy,
but this is a good example of how the
motive forces that configure your world
are dependent on instinctual forces that
are not only beyond your consciousness,
but they're beyond even at the moment
any of our explicit explanations.
So,
uh,
another finding that's very similar that
I came across recently turns out that
mice will not mate with mice that has rh
blood factors that are likely to
produce,
um,
unfit offspring.
Uh,
the more closely genetically related the
RH factors,
the more likely there is to be a,
uh,
a catastrophe with regards to offspring.
And the mice seem to detect the rh
factor by smell.
So recently this was run by with women.
And it is also the case that women
prefer man who's rh factors are at an
optimal distance from them in terms of
smell.
So this is some example of how these
unbelievably archaic systems,
cause like the olfactory systems are
unbelievably archaic,
produce alterations in Worldview at a
level that's massively below
consciousness.
So underneath your cortical shell,
which is tonically inhibiting all your
emotional and motivational systems,
lies all these motivational and
emotional systems and they have branches
that grow up into the cortex and they
have the capacity to control your
behavior completely involuntary.
So for example,
if you're gripped by fear,
it's very,
very difficult to overcome that
voluntarily.
And at least initially you won't be able
to,
which is to say that when the chips are
down,
the underlying motivation,
when emotional systems have control.
Okay,
so then what happens from that
perspective?
Then what happens when you encounter
something you don't understand?
And I think the best way to explain it,
it's something like generalized
disinhibition,
which is that all your underlying
motivational and emotional systems are
more or less disinhibited
simultaneously.
And the reason for that is because you
want to be maximally prepared to do
whatever the hell is necessary to do
when you're somewhere that you don't
understand and because you don't know
what that thing is going to be,
all your systems go on.
And when psychologists talk about
stress,
which is an abysmal word,
it means everything and nothing.
When psychologists talk about stress,
what they mean is generalized
disinhibition of emotion and motivation.
Then you come to the case of ancient
Egypt.
What are the things Lee Outta points
out,
which I think is really interesting.
I mean really phenomenal.
The story I'm going to tell you right
now was essentially revealed in Egyptian
culture at the dawn of the culture
rather than developing over the course
of the culture.
So the Egyptians had a revelation right
immediately that the most fundamental of
gods was the one who created as a
consequence of his tongue and his speech
very much akin to the
Sumerian idea.
With regards to Marta can also till
later Judeo Christian ideas.
So here's the story.
There's four players in this tram.
Okay.
There's Ocirus,
his wife,
Isis.
Yeah,
horace,
their son and Seth.
And Seth is,
Oh,
Sarah says evil brother.
Okay.
Now,
oh,
cirrus was a remarkable guy.
He was the founder of the Egyptian state
from the mythological perspective.
So kind of like Romulus and Remus for
Rome,
a myth or like George Washington for the
u s right.
A mythologized figure who represented
all of the Pharaohs and people for that
matter,
who'd actually constructed the Egyptian
state.
Oh,
cirrus farther of Egypt,
so to speak.
But it was,
Sarah's is Kinda old and little archaic
and maybe a little bit see now,
and even possibly a little bit naive in
that,
you know,
even no matter how great you were in
your youth,
as time goes on,
you lose contact with environmental
transformations and the old rules that
you live by or not necessarily
applicable to the present.
And some of those things that you ignore
become paramount of importance,
importance.
And it turns out that ocirus has an evil
brother Seth.
And Seth eventually turns into Satan as
mythology develops through the
centuries.
And Seth is a nasty guy,
right?
I mean,
okay.
What he wants more than anything is
undeserved dominion over the Egyptian
state.
No,
Sarah's because he's not paying
attention.
And because he isn't sufficiently
cognizant any more of the power of evil,
more or less,
ignores his evil brother who in turn
chop some into pieces and then
distributes his pieces all over the
Egyptian state.
Now you might say,
well,
why didn't he just kill up?
Right?
I mean,
you'd think chopping them up would kill
him,
but he's a god and you can't just kill
them.
The reason in mythology,
and you'll see this in movies as well,
where the villain never quite die,
so the hero never quite dies is because
even if you eliminate individual
embodiments of what those figures
represent,
new embodiments manifest themselves
virtually immediately.
So one of the things mythology is quite
clear about is that you never win a
final battle with evil.
It's a,
it's a prominent property of the world.
So anyways,
seth hacks up.
Sarah's spreads them all over the land.
Uh Oh,
Sarah sends up living a kind of shadowy,
a nebulous ghostlike existence down in
the underworld and seth becomes the
ruler of the state.
A nasty story.
All right,
bud.
Oh,
cirrus has isis as a wife now isis had a
huge cult.
She was a powerful goddess.
Goddess of the underworld are kind of
combination of Kelly and Diana,
so to speak,
capable of tremendous destructive power,
but also the source of all good things.
Something very much like tire map.
Now Isis got wind of her husband's
disintegration,
so to speak,
and she went searching around Egypt till
she found his fellas and with that she
makes herself pregnant.
Okay,
so what does that mean exactly?
It means something like this.
The collapse of any great order
brings with it new potential.
And I think this is something that
capitalism has way over forms of
government like communism.
Capitalism has mechanisms in place to
allow large structures that are no
longer needing their function to
collapse,
but frequently when they collapse,
it's not like they disintegrate into
dust,
right?
They disintegrate into sub components,
so to speak,
many of which then come to terms with
the fact that the order has collapsed
and build something new.
So you can't get rid of culture so
easily.
You can hack it up into bits.
You could disembody it,
so to speak.
You can spread it all over the state.
You could introduce chaos into it,
but that's,
that's something that has the potential
of new birth,
like the Phoenix rising from the ashes.
So anyways,
Isis,
who's the matrix,
who's tire Matt Gets,
Oh,
Sarah says fellas,
which is the container of the germ of,
of culture,
right?
That the,
the phenomena that's capable of the
seminal idea and she makes herself
pregnant and she gives birth to horace,
who's the long lost son of the rightful
king,
right?
A very typical mythological motif.
Okay,
so porous is alienated from the kingdom,
which is another very common
mythological motif.
You know,
like how King Arthur for example,
is raised by commoners.
This same story pops up in,
in,
uh,
in the story of Christ,
for example,
because Christ has heavenly parents.
But then he also has his kind of
ordinary parents and it's a very common
motif.
Anyway,
so horace grows out outside of the
classical structure of the Egyptian
state,
which is tilted terribly towards evil
because seth is dominated because it was
serious,
was too blind to his evil brother to
take appropriate defensive actions and
he grows to maturity.
And then he decides like all rightful
sons of the long lost king to reclaim
his heritage.
So he goes back to Egypt,
right?
And he has this vicious battle with seth
and in the process,
SEF tares out one of his eyes.
Well,
fine.
And that's an indication of just exactly
how devastating a battle with the forces
of evil,
so to speak,
precisely are they represent a critical
threat to the integrity of
consciousness.
Right?
That's why he loses an eye.
Well,
luckily enough,
horace has got his act together and he
does defeat seth and he banishes him and
it gets the eye back and then you think,
okay,
great.
Pop the eye back in,
become emperor,
everything's fine.
Now let's backtrack a little bit and
think about this politically.
Now,
the Egyptians had this really weird
idea.
They had the idea that the living
pharaoh was the living pharaoh and the
dead pharaoh at the same time.
That makes no sense rationally,
but it makes a lot of sense from a
narrative perspective because what they
were saying is something like this,
look,
you got to think that when you become
king or when you become president,
or when you take on a role of that
absolute magnitude that then you're
partly you,
but you're also partly this role and
there's really no way out of that.
Right?
And the role is composed of the
unbelievable weight of the cultural
tradition that you're representing.
And you can say,
well that's true for being king and for
being president.
But it's also true if you become a
doctor or a lawyer,
any sort of specialized occupation,
it's partly you cause you're embodying
the role.
But it's partly the role too.
So the pharaohs,
the live Pharaoh and the dead feral
because the dead feral represents
culture,
right?
The king is dead long live the king.
Okay.
But paralleling that idea was the idea
that the pharaoh was not only the dead
Pharaoh and the live pharaoh at the same
time,
but that he was ocirus and horace at the
same time.
But then you think in this story horace
has taken over,
Seth is God as I back,
he can be king,
but he isn't king yet.
And this is where the Egyptians really
get their act together.
And,
and I think of the two stories that I'm
telling you,
this is the one that has the most
significance,
I think for modern people because we're
so likely to sidestep our obligation to
our culture,
whatever that happens to be.
So instead of popping this I back in his
head,
which is the first thing you'd think he
does,
he decides he's going to go back to the
underworld where ocirus is living in
this ghostlike and dead manners since
he's been chopped up by seth.
So he goes down into the underworld,
which is no piece of cake and he finds
those serious,
they're in this kind of half dead state
and it gives him his eye
and that enlightens ocirus.
Right?
It gives him vision.
And so then he takes so serious back to
Egypt,
arm in arm,
so to speak.
And it's the conjunction of ocirus and
Hori Horis that constitutes the basis
for Egyptian sovereignty.
And that is bloody brilliant,
right?
Because the Egyptians figured out that,
so horace,
his tongue is Marduk for all intents and
purposes,
right?
He's this avenging hero in the Egyptian
story.
He fights political corruption rather
than chaos.
But you can understand that those are
two flip sides of the hero archetype.
They,
they are,
the hero archetype has two basic
elements.
One is the confrontation of the terrible
aspect of nature.
Chaos in its most brutal form.
And the other is the confrontation with
the archaic aspect of culture.
And in some ways those aren't
distinguishable because if culture isn't
archaic,
chaos never makes itself present.
So which is to say you can't separate
out political degradation from
environmental degradation.
Say it's the same idea.
So anyways,
horace has this great idea.
He needs his father,
right?
And I told you about the same motif
emerging in Pinocchio.
We already locked at that,
right?
Pinocchio doesn't become genuine until
he risks his life saving is farther.
All right?
So the same thing is happening in this
particular situation.
So that's pretty cool.
So then you get this situation where the
Egyptians characterize sovereignty as
the capability to overcome evil in the
political domain combined with,
and that's a youthful capability,
right?
Combined with the wisdom of the past.
All right?
Then you look at that from a political
perspective and you find out already
that the Egyptians viewed the Pharaoh as
the live pharaoh and the dead pharaoh
simultaneously.
But then you find out something else
that's interesting and it gives you some
really real insight into just exactly
how bloody powerful these ideas were.
So you think,
what did the Egyptians do with their
spare time?
And then you think,
well,
they built the pyramids,
right?
I mean,
and that was no trivial undertaking.
It was sort of the,
uh,
5,000 BC equivalent of flying to Mars.
And I mean,
the pyramids are pretty impressive now,
but they were a hell of a lot more
impressive in their original form
because they were in the middle of an
immense complex.
And the pyramids were dedicated to the
immortality of the Pharaoh.
And the Pharaoh was possessed by a
spirit called car.
And car was his,
his immortal spirit.
And it was the union of Horace and
ocirus.
Okay.
So Egyptian society was dedicated to a
day of flying the immortal spirit of the
Pharaoh,
the Union of Horace and ocirus.
And,
uh,
it was this union that gave the f,
it was this identification with this
union that gave the Pharaoh a phenomena.
The Egyptians called Matt and not was
like truth or good order.
And you can think about it as conscience
in a census,
if the Pharaoh was,
was utilizing the union of horizontals,
or I know serious than he would have an
intuitive ability to decide what the
appropriate course of order was.
And so the Egyptians would say,
for example,
when the Pharaoh came into the court,
they'd say the sun has risen.
And by that they meant that the power
that reigned over the dominion of the
night had arrived.
They conceptualized Matt has the
capacity to put order in the place of
chaos,
essentially,
formally.
So they assimilated the Union of Horace.
And ocirus with the capability of
putting order in the face of chaos.
They regarded that as a mortal and they
spent all of the excess resources of
their society glorifying that idea.
And you think you don't produce
something like the pyramids without
really being possessed by an idea,
right?
This is no trivial undertaking.
It's going over a period of several
hundred if not several thousand years.
And it takes an awful lot of work.
So this idea of the mortality of the
Union of Horace and Ocirus and its
association with sovereignty was an
absolutely potent idea for the
Egyptians.
It gave their whole culture motive
force.
Okay,
so the Egyptians thought Pharaohs and
mortal and not the reason why,
and we more or less partake in his and
mortality by being his subject.
So that was a pretty good deal.
But then Eliod of points out something
very interesting,
and this is called the democratization
of ocirus.
And what you found was that initially
there were certain symbolic
representations representing the
immortality of the Pharaoh that could
only be used by the Pharaoh.
But as Egyptian culture continued to
develop,
then the symbolic representations,
if a mortality started to be adopted by
the aristocracy,
and what did that mean?
It meant that this,
this process that the Egyptians had
conceptualized as integral to the order
of the state was no longer solely
embodied in the hands of the Pharaoh,
right?
It had started to drift down the power
hierarchy into the aristocracy.
Okay,
well then you think what happens after
that?
So by the end of Egyptian society,
the aristocrats were characterized by
an identity with the union of Horace and
Ocirus,
right?
Sovereignty had started to spread
itself.
Oh,
then you think what starts to happen
with the greats,
right?
The Greeks attribute to sovereignty to
every male,
Greek barbarians,
no women,
no,
but at least all males,
right?
You get a beginning of a democratic
notion there.
Um,
the Jews developing ideas that if not
derived from Egypt,
where at least similar in structure to
Egyptian ideas,
say not the aristocracy knock the
pharaoh,
but every individual has the capacity of
establishing a direct relationship with
the form of the Daddy,
right?
Then you have a Christian revolution
that follows that where the idea that
sovereignty and Harrison,
the individual is distributed to
everyone,
right?
Everyone,
male,
female,
criminal,
dawn,
criminal murderer,
rapist tax man,
you name it,
sovereignty and here is within them and
it's on that soil that our whole
democratic culture emerges.
These unbelievably archaic ideas first
acted out right first embodied in ritual
first dramatized,
then only told his stories,
developing more and more coherence over
over stretches of time of thousands of
years,
not hundreds of years,
but thousands of years becoming more,
more coherent,
becoming more pointed,
becoming more relevant with regards to
their embodiment.
Then starting to become understood
explicitly and distributed through the
entire society
and it's on that ground that our world
rests not on the ground of rationality
as established in say Europe in 1500
what we have is much more profound and
solid and deep.
Then any mirror,
rational construction,
it's,
it's a form of government and the
calibrated state so to speak.
That's a consequence of an emergent,
if not evolutionary,
at least social evolutionary process.
And I would say that it stems much
farther back than that because you can
imagine something like this,
look,
if this ideal personality that should be
sovereign is represented by the optimal
combination of creativity and
traditionalism,
say if that's the optimal combination
and if we're prepared to regard that as
optimal,
if,
if that's what you perceive when you
perceive someone that you respect and
admire her,
then you could say that success in our
social hierarchies is predicated on the
degree to which you actually embody that
combination.
And then you see an interaction between
individual success and this social
construction.
That would be an interaction that
extends over the centuries or even
thousands of century so that as these
ideas become more and more developed,
we become more and more adapted to
embodying them as a consequence of
evolutionary pressure.
So it's not just cultural,
it's also biological.
So our political presuppositions rest on
a cultural basis,
which is unbelievably archaic,
resting in turn on something even lower
than that.
And I think examples of that or are
those that I've provided you with
already.
We know for example,
that chimps who have to live in a
dominance hierarchy,
a very aggressive,
especially the males,
but they're also very cooperative,
so the males who are aggressive spend a
substantial amount of time repairing
social boundaries in the aftermath of a
aggressive incident because they're just
as concerned with keeping the bloody
hierarchy intact as they are in climbing
it.
They have to be.
Yeah,
and we know that even wolves won't kill
a subordinate wolf once they've defeated
it,
they allow the subordinate wolf to
maintain its own existence.
Right?
They have this notion,
this procedural notion that even those
entities that appear insignificant may
in some manner that's beyond speech,
still contribute to the integrity of the
whole,
and that's an idea that's very much
similar to our notion that sovereignty
in Harrison,
the individual,
right.
We've taken further.
No matter what you do,
even if you're in clear violation of the
law,
your rights remain in tact because no
matter how outcast you are and how
apparently beyond redemption,
your existence may still contribute
something to the integrity of the hall.
And as far as I'm concerned,
that doesn't appear to be a metaphorical
idea.
If you dismiss it,
you cannot dismiss it without
simultaneously dismissing the ground on
which our state's rest.
And so then you have to ask yourself,
are you willing to do that?
And if the answer is no,
well then you have to start doing,
you have to start to question what it is
that you actually believe.
Because if you buy the doctrine of
natural rights,
which you do,
you act it out,
then all of this follows in its wake,
or it rests on sand and it bloody well
better not rest on sound.
Okay?
Yeah.